hi everyone
i'm maurice samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
you to today's benjamin
and barbara zucker lecture part of our
ongoing lecture series this semester
exploring the relationship of
anti-semitism to other forms of racism
and prejudice so when i started to think
about organizing this
lecture series this summer i asked
colleagues for suggestions of speakers
and uh i was the the first name that
people suggested to me
was cheryl greenbergs and i was thrilled
that she accepted
our invitation to speak she's the paul
e rather distinguished professor of
history
at trinity college where she teaches and
writes on
african american history race relations
and 20th century civil rights and social
justice movements
she's written and edited a number of
books and articles but
most relevant for today's discussion is
troubling the waters
black jewish relations in the american
century published by princeton
university press
in 2010. she's currently editing a
memoir
of a civil rights worker and the
mississippi town he worked in
which should be out next year and also
working on a project about
the history of african american and
jewish american defense
agencies debates and shifting answers
about how to balance preventing hate
speech and protecting free speech
so the plan for today is that professor
greenberg is going to
speak for about 30 minutes and show us
some slides
and then we'll open it up for discussion
but audience members are muted uh
because this is a webinar so what i ask
you to do is please submit your
questions to me
using the q a function at the bottom of
the screen
not the chat function but the q a
function
please send me your questions as soon as
you think of them
even during the talk and then i will uh
ask them to professor greenberg now
please join me in welcoming
cheryl greenberg cheryl take it away
thank you thank you
um
um
first of all i just want to say how
honored i am to be part of such a
terrific series
um and i especially want to give jeff
melnick a shout out he's
uh he helped me come up with my book
title uh and in some ways i wanna i'm
gonna be building on
the very interesting uh discussion
between him and anthony russell
and i want to emphasize two points that
they made first
that it is both difficult and dangerous
to compare african-americans
and jewish americans when the two
communities are largely
so separated by class and living under
very different circumstances
the second thing i want to stress is
that we often forget that many jews are
both
black and jewish so here when i say
or most people who talk about this say
jews
i'm really referring to white especially
eastern european
jews this overlooking of racial dynamics
in the american jewish community is
in fact one reason that i see for the
failures of
jews in the black jewish relationship
that is that jewish
whites ran all the powerful
organizations i'm going to be discussing
and never considered or consulted their
own communities members of color
but i'm getting ahead of myself
okay uh before 2016
i gave these sorts of talks in a context
of a resurgent
optimistic liberal energy and within
that
an enthusiasm of both african-american
and jewish groups to see if we could
once more join
forces to advance the causes that both
communities endorse
the question i was asking then was how
do we harness this energy
to move forward how quaint
now we are in what feels like an
entirely new moment
of threat and danger although one with
historically familiar and frightening
overtones
even if we're not as many of us fear on
the verge of fascism
we are certainly at a moment where the
values that most of us cherish
egalitarianism justice democracy are
under threat
some of you may disagree and i'm happy
to make my case in the question and
answer period
but let's agree for the moment at least
that that sense of
optimism among both liberals and
progressives has turned into a grim
determination to fight against are
moving backward
so what do we do as a historian i say
look to the past if we want to rebuild
effective coalitions to protect and
promote those agendas that we value
we can do no better than to look at the
history of coalitions
between the ef between african-americans
and jewish americans not because that
coalition was smooth but precisely
because it wasn't
but it was still incredibly effective so
their successes could teach us all a
great deal about effective strategies
and possibilities
and their failures can instruct us about
potential pitfalls
in fact as i'll talk about some of this
rebuilding and some of this
sniping and infighting is already
happening
so today i'm going to violate every rule
of the historical profession and use the
past in the service of the present
i want to plumb the history of black
jewish relations for lessons to be
learned
i'm also going to violate every rule of
public speaking and give the conclusions
right up front
first that the black jewish coalition
and the broader liberal and progressive
coalition
won victories in so many areas of civil
rights
civil liberties liberties and economic
justice
while fighting internally that is in the
words of civil rights activist bernice
johnson reagan we learned that quote
you can get things done even when you're
in a mess unquote
blacks and jews in other words looked up
from their immediate differences and by
keeping their broader goals in mind
move forward together and second
that this coalition was weakened not
just by class
and racial differences which i will talk
about but also
by divergent political understandings of
those class and racial difference that
that
those class and racial differences led
to most particularly
about the liberal goal of race blindness
and the invisibility of white privilege
to jews who did not see themselves
as entirely white
the fact is that a tie between the black
and jewish communities
uh bond has long been expressed
and not just among leaders as some have
argued
consider obama jewish outreach or jews
for obama
there are no swedes for obama or obama
methodist outreach
norris is feeling just among jews as
other people have claimed
the naacp protest swastikas and
anti-semitic incidents
black churches support israel and they
rallied in pittsburgh
after the synagogue shooting and as i
recently learned
martin luther king's birthday is also
national
bagel day who knew
i'm not claiming although i wish i could
that there's something inherent in our
two people something natural
about any affinity between blacks and
jews there's nothing special about
jewish ethics that makes jews more
likely than christians
to care about black equality there were
no jews in the leadership ranks of the
abolitionist movement
in fact one southern rabbi who spoke
against slavery was run out of town
by his own congregation reform and
secular jews far outnumbered the
orthodox
and civil rights work nor is there
anything special about our both being
oppressed minority groups
so were the irish so were the japanese
they generally did not make common cause
with other
out groups in fact more often they tried
to embrace whiteness
so as to be integrated into the
mainstream more quickly
but what i am claiming is that something
happened
to make african-americans and white jews
because after all black jews were
already there moved toward each other
you know in the way that they did which
is actually if you think about it a
heartening notion that communities
like individuals have real choices that
they can make
that there's no such thing as political
predestination
well if it's not natural but it came
about from some set of historical
conditions or events
then better understanding those
conditions can perhaps serve as a model
for us moving forward
so if i'm right what helped create that
political bond
and why did it come apart what worked
and what should be
what should we be careful not to do
again and that
is a job for a historian so i'm going to
do a quick
skip through history of black jewish
relations in the us the good
the bad and as promised the lessons to
learn
african americans and jewish americans
have had very different histories
but they had some common experiences
around the turn of the 20th century
they had they both migrated into urban
areas
over 2 million jews from eastern europe
and russia
and over a million african americans
moved south to north
in a in a move so massive that they call
it the great
migration they had common experiences of
discrimination
and exclusion from jobs neighborhoods
schools
and housing
and there was hatred and violence while
racism was of course
much more virulent in the united states
than anti-semitism
both had been known to erupt into lethal
violence
so in response and like other groups
african americans and jewish americans
banded together
to form organizations to help them
in the african-american community for
example there's a national
association of colored women in 1896
the naacp in 1909 the national urban
league the national council of negro
women
and among the their jewish counterparts
were the national council of jewish
women
in 1893 and by the way in both
communities notice
women led the way which is a fact truth
of the entire civil rights movement but
that's a story for another time
anyway the american jewish committee in
1906 the adl
in 1913 the american jewish congress and
the jewish labor committee
but while both these groups had the same
goal which was equal opportunity
and full inclusion in american life
virtually no white organization was
willing to work with black groups in
order to achieve it
that was not true of the left who did
but that's also a story for another time
certainly individual jews and blacks
work together
of the naacp's founders for example a
disproportionate number of white
of white founders were jewish
black and jewish intellectuals in the
early 20th century
uh including horace callan allen locke
and franz boaz
challenged the assimilationist rhetoric
of what was called
a hundred percent americanism which i
think is
code for only wasp culture can make
america great again make america great
again
but their idea was called pluralism that
all groups have different cultures and
traditions that we should celebrate
they're not a threat because underneath
we all share basic values
we're all distinct but we're not
separatist we are part of what makes the
united states
but jews like other whites hesitated to
get involved with african-americans on a
broader level
as an anti-defamation league leader
reasoned the difficulties facing the
jews as a minority group
are sad enough without tying ourselves
up with another minority group of less
influence
and by so doing probably taking on some
of their troubles
a group whose difficulties in my
estimation are even more deplorable
than our own as i said that was true for
most
white and other minority groups they
continued to stand apart
but jews moved why is that
really it changed in the 1930s with the
rise of nazism
and fascism here and in europe
jews reached out to african americans
for help
leading uh combining to do to work in
things like holding anti-racism rallies
here there's dubois
and um and stephen wise speaking
at an anti-racism uh rally in new york
and african americans took the
opportunity to link nazi racism to
racism here at home
like in the double v campaign victory
abroad and victory at home
or in this naacp telegram that they sent
to the state department on christelnacht
american negroes share the indignation
at the outrages of the nazi government
but we would be even more enthusiastic
if our government could be equally
indignant at the lynching
of american citizens by american mobs on
american soil
which have shamed america for a much
longer time
clearly this was based on self-interest
in on both sides
so for those keeping score lesson one
for those looking to build coalitions
start with self-interest that
self-interest broadened over the next
two decades into an act of collaboration
on a wide range of civil rights issue
and again the question is why
and really it's for the same reason that
crimes are successful
time and opportunity the moment was
right
for jews who didn't want to call
attention to anti-semitism
for fear that that would give it a wider
platform
they pushed for broad
anti-discrimination legislation
and nazism in fact the whole of jewish
history taught them that if today's
target was african were
african-americans
then the jews always came next for
african-american leaders
jews seemed a powerful and
well-organized ally one they could
persuasively
appeal to particularly given the nazi
threat
to make collaboration work both black
and jewish leaders emphasized the common
plight of
blacks and jews their shared suffering
this is a pamphlet
obviously from the adl that basically
argues the clan hates african-americans
today
but don't you worry they're going to
come after the jews tomorrow
another adl uh spokesperson said we know
we jews know what restrictions mean we
too have faced handicaps
because of this jews show such deep
interest in the negro's problems
the yiddish press had long covered lynch
mobs and called and called them pogroms
and the deteriorating situation of
german jews
received extensive coverage in black
newspapers
so what launched the black jewish
collaboration by the late 1930s
wasn't a broadening of the challenge to
discrimination but the decision to work
against it together
still that was a pivotal shift it meant
that both communities had redefined
their self-interest as including the
concerns of others
what i call a spacious sense of
self-interest
lesson two making common cause
but spatial space spacious self-interest
isn't just understanding that lynching
and pogroms are both constitute
a similar kind of oppression it's
recognizing the link
between those issues rearticulating
one's own agenda in a more universalist
way
this wasn't about blacks or jews alone
but
all americans only by attacking all
forms of bigotry
could any group be safe and so leaders
in both communities
emphasized that all civil rights issues
were interconnected
and so self-interest lay in a
broad-based attack on inequalities
and that we were all fighting the same
fight
and this brings us to lesson three
articulate that broader
spacious self-interest as a universalist
vision
of national moral concern as
martin luther king put it about the
civil rights movement if we are wrong
the supreme court of this nation is
wrong if we are wrong
the constitution of the united states is
wrong
if we are wrong god almighty is wrong
and it worked in 1938 a black baptist
church
raised funds for jewish refugees sending
with its money
this note as a race of people whose
souls have been made sensitive through
many years of persecution and suffering
we extend our profoundest symptom
sympathies to the jewish people
in their present plight and there was a
wartime detroit study
that showed that not only did black
people ex
expect more of jewish people given their
shared sense of
victimization but jews themselves felt
that way
the jews should be expected to do better
than other white people
for this to be meaningful you have
lesson four that you must educate your
own community
about this expansive social vision
so for example in new york city there
were many complaints about white
exploitation of black domestics
black women would stand on street
corners white women would come and pick
them up
and often take advantage of them not pay
them whatever
but only jews respond to the problem and
what they do is they set up
an employment agency where
african-american women can come
and white women can come and hire them
but notice who's doing the hiring in
other words emphasizing black jewish
similarity and suffering
masked crucial racial and class
differences between the two communities
which would later help erode the con the
coalition
and a small aside here in case i haven't
provoked enough of you yet
all this occurred over the protests of
many southern jews
who had both absorbed local racial views
and feared speaking up that would
provoke anti-semitism
and actually they were right they not
only kept quiet
but they begged their northern jewish
counterparts to be quiet
or at least stay out of their
communities but that's also another
story
but i'm large so i'm largely speaking
here not only about white jews but about
northern white jews
who saw united action in civil rights in
the jewish self-interest in that more
spacious sense these
political changes in the black and
jewish communities were affected also by
changing u.s
politics there was a new public rhetoric
that emerged
first in wartime because the war
demanded unity
news and genocidal violence of genocidal
violence in europe
made the united states made the united
states emphasize the importance of
tolerance
and pluralism at least rhetorically
and the emergent cold war reminded us
that overt discrimination and
segregation in the united states was the
best propaganda that the ussr had
to win non-white non-aligned nations to
their side
so the result was a newly shaped
political liberalism
that understood rights as rooted
individual in individuals
not groups they advocated it advocated
access to employment to housing to
voting civic life
all protected from discrimination based
on one's group membership
it was moderate because it was
anti-communist but this moderate
moderation was okay because it was
pluralist
since we're all the same under the skin
all we have to do is change our hearts
and all else will follow
and the coalition building between black
and jewish organizations was spurred
and shaped by this new liberalism and
you see it in every joint
black and jewish venture on behalf of
integration
in the 1940s and 1950s among local and
national groups among leadership
and grassroots where the said where
segregation was the law
they challenged it where it violated the
law they took discriminators to court
they proposed civil rights planks for
democratic and republican platforms
yes republican platforms they testified
before congressional committees on civil
rights civil liberties
and social welfare legislation they
co-sponsored letter-writing campaigns
and petitions
they co-sponsored lobbying efforts they
conferred on legislative and legal
strategies
and they focused on civic education
because
liberal liberalism focuses on treating
people as individuals
not members of groups it implied that
that discrimination operated on the
basis of individual attitudes and
behaviors
so black and jewish agencies produced
educational materials for schools
churches and civic groups that stress
pluralism
and tolerance based on the assumption
again that more united groups
then divided them the changing people's
beliefs
and behaviors was the key to achieving
true equality
in other words discrimination was
explained not by white people protecting
their advantage
but by personal bigotry once again
though
notice who is the boss and who is the
employee
and their spacious sense univ sorry and
their spacious
universalist articulation of liberal
values meant that these collaborative
efforts went far beyond direct
self-interest
segregation laws for example did not
affect jews
but all the major jewish organizations
filed briefs for the brown decision
and dozens of earlier and lesser-known
civil rights cases
and the naacp fought for higher
immigration immigration quotas for
jewish refugees
and they lobbied the haitian liberian
and filipino u.n delegations to support
the creation of israel
and these successes were notable
black and jewish agencies and their
allies desegregated hospitals
schools housing projects unions bowling
leagues restaurants
beaches medical and legal associations
local coalitions passed
anti-discrimination and anti-kkk
legislation and by the way also
anti-mask legislation interesting today
in dozens of cities they integrated
workplaces
they challenged the poll tax they fought
segregated housing
in hollywood a black and jewish group
challenged racial and ethnic
stereotyping in movies
and in new york it was a joint black and
jewish
effort that created sunni the state
university system in order to compensate
for racial and religious discrimination
at private colleges
they opened social and economic
opportunities expanded
anti-discrimination protections
extended educational and legal equality
and expanded the social services
safety net but while all this was
happening there were also powerful
tensions between the two communities
because most blacks and jews remained
divided by race
religion and class which had real but
unrecognized impacts on people's
attitudes
and that was because of liberty
liberalism's limits
which largely which largely ignored race
and class
implications especially because talking
about those issues sounded suspiciously
like communism
and by focusing on individuals they
missed structural problems
institutional racism that went beyond
personal bias
in other words theoretical liberal race
by race blindness was not enough
that's because racial discrimination and
its consequences had trapped african
americans
north and south into low wage low
mobility employment
and that was a structural problem
eastern european jews
had also begun life here at the bottom
but those similarly poor
they had come from urban areas and often
had skills unavailable
to most black rural agricultural workers
and these two factors plus good timing
and white skin
helped them rise economically despite
anti-semitism
but most jews who were committed to this
individualist
liberal ethic didn't recognize the role
that structural racism played
in limiting black progress and so we
come to lesson five
you can't find effective solutions if
you ignore
the structures of discrimination
so here are jews who are primarily white
and economically more successful
which of course are related working in
african-american neighborhoods
because they also are a bit less racist
jews see themselves as open and tolerant
rising on hard
work they don't see themselves as white
they were persecuted by white people in
europe
but african americans do see jew do see
jews as white
they had economic benefits because they
were white even though jews may not have
seen
it so because jews were in black
neighborhoods
black people saw them not as social
outsiders
but as insiders exploiting black
outsiders
and they protest
jews see these protests as anti-semitism
while black people see it as rich white
people soaking black
soaking poor black people and at the
same time
historic christian anti-semitism
sometimes turned black
class resentment into anti-semitic
expressions
as james baldwin famously wrote negroes
are anti-semitic
because they're anti-white
to be explicit then even as they made
common cause politically
black and jewish collaboration weakened
because racial and class differences
still divided most blacks and jews
but by and large that fact went
unacknowledged and unaddressed
lesson six positionality matters
people view the same situations
differently depending on where they
stand
their priorities their values or their
access to power
despite these tensions and despite jews
increasing economic status jewish groups
continued to support
civil rights efforts with their black
colleagues well they did the so well
into the 60s
including demonstrations
marches and lobbying
and the hardest and most dangerous
organizing work this of course is
goodman schwerner and cheney
uh who disappeared at the beginning of
mississippi freedom summer
and were found uh under a dam
and the two heads of the leadership
conference on civil rights
were roy wilkins of the naacp and arnold
aronson who from the national jewish
community relations advisory council
but the jewish sorry but the liberal
consensus was fraying around them
by the mid-1960s to many especially
young people
liberalism seemed to have failed the
movement there was no federal protection
for those engaged in legal activities
like registering to vote
the attacks on on civil rights folks
went unpunished
and at the democratic national
convention in 1964
that allegedly liberal party refused to
sit the black
sit the integrated black mississippi
delegation
to replace the one elected by an illegal
all-white primary
and king was attacked in chicago one of
the bastions of norm
of northern liberalism
all this provokes black nationalism
militants
and black power snick and co student on
violent coordinating committee
and corps became all all black you see
the rise of the
black panther party their argument was
you can't
trust white liberals because when
they're forced to choose
they act not as liberals but as white
people
they also criticized liberalism for
its commitment to integration it was
unachievable
but it was also cultural genocide
and their alliance with other groups of
color and anti-colonial movements
moved many black people to repeatedly
criticize israel
for its treatment of palestinians and
this hurt
jewish the jewish community despite
reassurances from established black
leaders
meanwhile jews were rethinking their own
commitments this was not about israel
not just about israel i should say they
saw black nationalism and separatism as
a
wound in the heart that they saw
radicalism as a tactical error
that it will alienate moderates who were
still needed to pass civil civil rights
legislation
and as civil the civil rights movement
moved north into the neighborhoods of
these liberal jews
the question of integration took on a
different meaning
i should just point out that these fha
um real estate maps where they
redlined that is not provide mortgages
for homes
uh in african-american and changing
neighborhoods
i include hartford because that's where
i'm from i include new york city because
it is
the center of the universe and of course
we can't forget
new haven
with concerns couched in class rather
than racial terms
many white jews fled from the cities to
the suburbs almost as quickly as white
christians
to avoid what they perceived as the
deterioration of their schools and
neighborhoods
as municipal services declined with the
white population
jewish leaders recommended patience in
moderation to their black colleagues
but black leaders to whom in king's
words later as almost always meant
never they read this isn't as evidence
that jews could not be relied on
as allies that really wasn't true
most jews still believed in a liberalism
that focused on individuals rather than
groups
and their blindness to the benefits that
white skin brought had allowed them to
believe
that they had risen on their own merits
and so black people could do the same if
they just
kept going unable to see the limits of
their own liberalism
these white jews fundamentally
misunderstood
the frustration and anger of many black
activists
and they felt that african-americans
were moving away from the political
vision that they had shared
lesson seven position map
positionality or standpoint matters
everyone interprets events from their
own perspective
avoiding those sorts of
misunderstandings requires intentionally
incorporating multiple viewpoints into
any political analysis
and being wary of potential paternalism
or assumptions of a
quid pro quo except around the edges
this really did not happen
and i do want to point out here again
that the failure
to think through different perspectives
is nowhere clearer
than in the failure of jewish
organizations almost exclusively white
to bring in jews of color it's why
black jewish relations really means
black white jewish
relations it was exactly on
these tensions and divisions
that collaboration foundered diverging
political understandings became visible
in occasions
of direct black jewish confrontation and
division
for example in ocean hill brownsville in
1968
which pre which pitted a primarily black
community
against a primarily jewish teachers
union
so many saw this as a black jewish
confrontation
or the affirmative action cases of the
1970s bakke
and defunus black agencies filed briefs
on behalf of african americans
while most jewish groups filed briefs in
opposition
this was the first time that blacks and
jews black and jewish organizations
had publicly positioned themselves on
opposite sides
of a civil rights case for jews
affirmative action violated the
race-blind
individual individualist liberalism
liberalism that they still believed in
they argued that explicit consideration
of group membership
was the antithesis of liberalism
but for black people african affirmative
action was crucial
to close the gap between the rhetoric of
race blindness
and the reality of continued
discrimination and structural
or institutionalized racism
other examples of black jewish conflict
became nastier
there was crown heights in 1991
and there was public there were public
expressions of black anti-semitism
most notably in uh minister farrakhan
and the nation of islam
but it wasn't just political differences
or violence that lessened cooperation
the jewish community had changed it was
now
economically largely middle class
and now living primarily in suburbs jews
and their agencies turned their
attention away from the problems of
poverty and urban life
some went further neoconservatives
argued that liberalism had been
transformed into favoritism
social disorganization bloated budgets
and a nanny state
in other words if black nationalism
challenged liberalism from one side
a jewish shift towards conservatism and
parochialism
did so on the other and the outgrowth of
this sort of distrust of others also led
to what we now call identity politics
which refocused or narrowed what each
group defined as its self-interest
and its particular concerns
meanwhile the gap between black and
white incomes and life chances which had
begun to shrink in the 1960s and 70s
widened again a white backlash
which swept first nick richard nixon
then ronald reagan
and then donald trump into office in
each case
reversed recent progress toward
educational and residential
desegregation
and weakened civil rights laws and
remedies
and in each case we have seen a public
discourse return to the familiar
and chillingly racist rhetoric of us
versus
them which cast african americans
outside the boundaries
of american society joined after 9 11 by
muslims
and now at least i would argue the
dangerous them also includes immigrants
feminists queer folks and jews
this broader othering means that
anti-civil rights efforts have expanded
further
from racially targeted travel bans to
ice deportations of non-criminal
long-term residents with families and
the storing of immigrant children
in cages i could go on but i will start
frothing at the mouth
so instead let's go back to our story
so by the 1980s or so blacks and jews
face
very different problems and liberalism
especially the fractured liberalism that
emerged out of the chaos of the 1960s
and 70s
seemed either unable to solve them or
discredited altogether
and that's where the story usually ends
but i'm not convinced that liberalism
died or that most blacks and jews
weren't
and aren't still motivated by liberal
and progressive values
instead they shifted their attention to
different sets of liberal values
liberal issues i should say the jewish
community has until
recently at least largely focused on
cultural pluralism
sustaining jewish identity and israel as
a safe haven for pers
from persecution which is arguably
narrower but still liberal
for african americans traditional
liberal concerns about poverty and
discrimination
continued to dominate their political
agenda and they felt
betrayed by jews shift away from those
issues
so since blacks and jews no longer
understood themselves as sharing
priorities
and had largely discarded the rhetoric
of universalism
in favor of self-assertion it's not
surprising that their partnership
withered
but that doesn't mean that either ever
abandon liberalism
or the basic values they had shared the
fact is
that all along most white jews still
looked a lot like traditional liberals
in their lesser risk re in their less
lesser level of racism and their
continued
commitment to traditional civil rights
and their attitude
towards social issues and certainly in
their self-protect
self-perception there's that old jewish
jewish joke
jews earn like episcopalians and vote
like puerto ricans
and most jews still identified as
liberals and they too felt betrayed
by the perceived their perceived
rejection by the black community
and anyway during those years i'd argue
liberal political cooperation didn't
cease
the media just didn't cover it it wasn't
sensational
black and jewish groups continued and
continue today to collaborate on
strengthening aid to public education
on anti-poverty programs and access to
health care on hate crimes
and anti-discrimination legislation on
voting rights
on women's rights and gender equality or
at least now to fight
uh to protect what we have from being
stripped away all together
they continue to challenge outbursts of
genocidal violence
and racial and religious hatred they
both still monitor
all cases of bigotry and they continue
their tolerance work
which is now called diversity or
inclusion
and in the most recent african-american
most recent affirmative action
cases most jewish groups filed briefs
in favor of affirmative action now
more jewish and now more jews understand
the conflict
between race blind theory and existing
structures of inequality
in fact blacks and jews are still the
two groups most likely to vote
democratic
93 and 70 respectively in 2012
so you know compared with 39 percent of
whites
30 80 and 74 in 2016
90 and 79 in 2018
they are still the highest two groups
historically higher
even than gays and lesbians although not
surprisingly in 2016
the lgbt community slightly edged out
jews
both communities remain invested in the
politics that underlay the civil rights
coalition
and both groups have reasserted the
importance of working together
even in crown heights for almost a
decade now
well before trump emerged as i mentioned
in the beginning there's been a striking
new energy in both communities
to tackle broad social problems from
voting rights to lgbtq
equality from ongoing discrimination to
strengthening civic engagement
and to do so in coalition and that's
been visible
in national forums like partnerships
between the national urban league and
the american jewish committee
the coalition of black trade unionists
and the jewish labor committee
the reform movement's religious action
center and the naacp's voter
registration project
and the new congressional black jewish
caucus
it's also obvious in local church
and synagogue links and action groups
across the country
like black boston's black jewish
economic roundtable
operation understanding great neck black
jewish dialogue
the thursday network in washington dc
toronto's blacks and jews and dialogue
the atlanta black jewish coalition
and then groups like carolina jews for
justice baltimore and washington's jews
united for justice
new york's jews for racial and economic
justice all partnering with allies of
color
around issues of racial and economic
justice
and dozens more black and jewish local
pairings
and even in musical groups like the
afro-semitic experience
in fact many of these local and national
links and efforts at making
common cause have begun or spur or
spurred their organizing
since 2016. but civil rights work has
become broader than exclusively black
jewish dialogue
or even black jewish partnerships today
the most active coalitions include the
intentionally broad
and intersectional movement for black
lives
showing up for racial justice our
revolution
move on moral monday's coalition the
women's march
indivisible and the like some jewish
groups have engaged with groups like
like black lives matter but others have
viewed them with fear
and suspicion and we can talk about some
of that in the quest and answer period
if you'd like
but i want to finish by asking how do
civil rights activists
more effectively engage with this new
old work
what does the history of black jewish
political collaboration tell blacks and
jews
and all who would rebuild broad social
justice coalitions
i would i would summarize and refashion
my list of lessons this way
don't lose sight of structural realities
institutional barriers to equal
opportunity
or deny the impact of race and class
when jews focused on our victimhood and
not on our privilege
we failed to recognize that most of our
success much of our success
in all fairness came from opportunities
and benefits accorded only to whites
and so we lost our ability to strategize
effectively to bring
down those barriers and we lost the
trust of our coalition partners
educate people about how those real but
often invisible barriers operate
and work actively to dismantle them in
both the broader society and in our own
communities
changing individual hearts and minds is
not enough
a race-blind vision of equality is not
enough
we have to be honest about what about
how these different racial and class
positions affect affected relationships
and
affect relationships of coalition
partners we need to explore
rather than ignore differences between
and within
communities we have to learn from the
ideas of intersectionality
to consider things from multiple
perspectives and standpoints
we have to look internally reinforce
one's own community's embrace of a
shared agenda
and challenge its parochialism it can't
always be
simply about the small us
we learned that the struggle is most
effective when it operates on all levels
national local men women elite
grassroots
and on many fronts simultaneously
lobbying
teaching legislating demonstrating
organizing negotiating
we have to focus on points of
commonality among among allies
and recognize that there are points of
difference without letting them stop
forward motion we have we have seen that
despite the real tensions between black
and jewish interests
throughout the 20th century jews stuck
with their civil rights commitments
and even nationalist black organizations
welcomed white allies
we can move even when things are in a
mess
similarly with points of difference
within one's own community
king and malcolm x disagreed about just
about everything
but malcolm was clear that they shared
the end goal if society rejected him
it rejected king excuse me it would have
to confront him
snick mockingly called king the lord
and young jewish activists pooh-poohed
the contributions of liberal jewish
organizations
and southern rabbis pushed against
northern jewish public expressions of
activism
but these internal divisions did not
prevent the work they all supported
from moving forward today there are
fierce disagreements within both the
black and the jewish communities about
how to proceed
hell i have disagreements with myself
you know to jews three opinions
we have to acknowledge them we have to
confront them and then find ways to move
on
despite them but most importantly
we have to return to that time when we
defined our self-interest
spaciously and together helped build a
movement
that transformed american society when
perceived self-interest narrowed
and became more parochial the movement
lost its momentum
we've also learned that talk is not
enough as we saw in the civil rights
struggle
change came only when talk moved to
action
and to stop pretending uh that i stopped
even pretending that i am a
dispassionate historian
i would argue we can't wait it's not
just the terrifying and malicious
actions of polish
president trump and his administration
although i'd be happy to list them
and the increased polarization and
hatred now so openly and dangerously
expressed
we also still face the challenges we did
before of underemployment and poverty
mass incarceration afraid safety net
global warning
and the grotesque disparities of wealth
that threaten our nation's well-being
challenges that have only intensified
and the weakening of civil rights
protections
not just under trump either have
re-segregated too much of society
and too too often compassion for others
the very idea
of civil society has vanished as a
motivation for action or legislation
the struggle against this has already
begun and how we move forward
is up to all of us but i do hope that
some of these findings
point toward some possibilities thank
you
thank you uh sheriff for that fantastic
talk that really
um was just so enlightening and and
inspiring too so thank you and there are
a lot of questions so i am going to
dive right in i had a lot of my own but
i am going to
ventriloquize um the audience's
questions um so there
are several questions about um
the palestinian-israeli conflict and
about
you know you you talked about how you
know originally there was black
solidarity with israel that
that black groups like the naacp uh
advocated um among you know black
countries to support the creation of
israel
but wondering how that has broken it
seems like it's broken down
uh since the occupation and what have
the consequences
been and how you see that
well as i started to suggest in the talk
really it's the alliances the
international alliances that
african-american groups made with
anti-colonization movements elsewhere
that really raised this whole question
about white imperialism that is european
imperialism into colonized non-white
areas and so that raised the question of
israel now seen as a
european nation of white people
colonizing
what was palestinian land
for a while this was sort of at the
fringes
of the african-american political
community because
mainstream black groups were not willing
to sacrifice the support of
jewish organizations and jews were very
prickly about this
but increasingly it's become expressed
as a frustration
especially as the occupation has gone on
and as israel has moved
towards more conservative views and so
uh what has what has emerged
is that i think any time there is
criticism of israel
it becomes translated by some people in
the jewish community
as anti-semitic and
here i'm speaking just to the jewish
community
i also think that uh jews have a
tendency to see
our relationship as the most in our
issues as the most important
so for example when the black lives
matter platform which was 130 odd pages
mentioned israel in one sentence many
jewish organizations took the
opportunity to say we're not gonna we're
not gonna get involved with them
i'm everybody has their own bright line
i'm not criticizing but it seems to
me that it is very convenient that in a
moment where we are
challenged to rise above our own
interests and
fight racism we manage to find the same
anti-semitic or anti-zionist criticism
that's been going on for a long time and
say
we're shocked shocked we're not going to
take part in this coalition
and so that's where i think you see me a
division among many people
many groups in the jewish community
we're not going to get involved because
of the line
we're going to get despite we're going
to get involved despite the line
and some cases we're going to get
involved because of the line
um yeah i mean there you know other
people ask specifically
about um the squad and ilhan
omar and um you know i know that that
has been
a big debate in my own family dinner
tables you know with
very concerned you know uh family
members
wanting to know but don't i you know
think that she was anti-semitic and
you know what what's your response to
someone who who asks you that question
um well
i'm probably not a good person to answer
this because i don't think it was
anti-semitic i think it was the comments
are either ignorant sometimes
or not very well thought out and
also reflect a bias toward palestinian
suffering that jews hear as
anti-zionism or anti-israel
but even if she were anti-semitic my
argument would be
lots of people disagree about lots of
things so
support her where she does good things
and yell at her when she does bad things
just like we do everybody else
i don't agree with anybody 100
there are as i said some bright lines
personally
i can't vote for donald trump because
he's a racist i don't care even if he
did wonderful things
that's a bright line for me other people
have other bright lines and i understand
that but my answer would be
she's a congresswoman she's not going to
affect foreign policy but she's going to
have a huge impact domestically
and so focus on those positions and see
how you like
them and if you can't embrace her that's
fine embrace
the agendas that she's that she has that
you do agree with
yeah i mean i would say i did think that
the thing
some of the things she said did cross
the line to being anti-semitic i mean
she
she used anti-semitic tropes but i did
think that
um it was as you said i think out of
ignorance and she did
you know when you know she didn't double
down you know
now i mean she did under you know take
it in the criticism and i think that
that's
that's worth something um uh so
to take you up on on something that you
mentioned at the start of your talk
which is that jews aren't all white um
so
we're wondering if we could several
people have asked
about how black jews fit into the story
you're telling uh well
first of all i know estimates range but
at this point
folks estimate that almost 20
of the jewish population in the united
states is non-white
doesn't mean they're all
african-american but are non-white and
they are
either folks who have been jewish all
along they are
products of a jewish non-jewish marriage
where the children have been raised
jewish they are converts there are all
sorts of ways in which
different communities have joined um the
jewish the white jewish community uh
it is now larger a larger group than it
was before but there have always been
black jews and and other jews of color
and my sense is that
what's different now is that we realize
it so
um for example i was invited to give a
talk at two different synagogues one in
dc
and one in new york who spent the year
this is before kovid before black lives
matter stuff
spent the year focusing on how to be
more inclusive in the jewish community
of jews of color so i think now it is an
agenda
to say oh look there are multiple pers
people here and we can't always have
this white
view and what i suggested in the
beginning at least i really do believe
which is that
if i'm correct that part of the problem
facing the black jewish coalition is the
jews didn't face their
racism or their white privilege they
could have done so had they only
recognized and talked to
the black jews in their midst and so by
ignoring the black
jewish community white jews missed out
on a whole set of opportunities to do
things better
very interesting okay so we have a
question from an anonymous attendee
it's an interesting question about how
jewish organizat as i understand this
question jewish organizations
um direct so much um
uh charitable uh efforts towards the
black community
um job training child care health care
you know and and also advocacy efforts
you know the
there's so many you know jews who who
think including
you know what we're doing here uh so the
question is
um does that help uh
black jewish relations does that help uh
black people
want liking jews or does it just seem
paternalistic
some of both maybe um i you know it's a
little bit like donald trump to suburban
women right
can't you just like me um yes
there is a certain level of paternalism
that has always
operated between blacks and jews that
the jewish group sort of
we know what we're doing here let us
help you
i think currently though
i think it is a different story
um again when i am contacted by
different groups i was asked by the
jewish
the american jewish archives to speak on
black jewish relations
what does an archive have to do with
black jewish relations the
my sense is that the jewish community is
seriously
thinking about white privilege and how
they
as white people have a certain
responsibility to educate themselves
about
racist structures and all of the
activism that i've seen
that engages black groups particularly
on the left
always talk about this they always
discuss
the issues of race the issues of um of
black jews or jewish black people right
so they
are absolutely engaged in as honest
a relationship and dialogue as they
possibly can be
so yes of course a richer organization
is going to seem paternalistic to a
to a poorer a poor group or whatever um
but i do actually think that most jews
that i know of at least
um are serious about rethinking
their relationship with the black
community and rethinking
the importance of that work for
themselves
right because it's in jewish and white
self-interest to have
a more equitable society
terrific okay last question because
we're almost out of time and it's a
great one
uh could you if you could recommend
three books
uh to white jews who want to better
understand the dynamics and play
which three books would you recommend oh
gosh of course yours and of course of
course
i will recommend yours again so for
everybody troubling the waters
black jewish relations in the american
century uh published by princeton
university press
it's a great question and i'm gonna punt
by saying
um that i think what jews have to do now
is think about
what white jews have to do now is think
about their role as white people
and so the same kind of list that people
have been putting up in general how to
be an anti-racist
um white fragility whatever
those sorts of books force white people
to confront
our own relationship with whiteness and
the ways in which
these discriminatory barriers operate
without us
as everybody could wake up non-racist
tomorrow and it wouldn't change anything
it wouldn't change a lot
right because these structures are in
place and so i think
uh just as i think every white person
has to come to grips with the way that
they have benefited from these invisible
wines and that black people have been
hurt
by those invisible barriers
so too to jews we now have an added
burden
in a way we're not just white we are
also jewish and so
what is the jewish obligation to help
tikkun alum to help repair the world and
to do so
without patronizing anybody to do so
without
being oblivious to things and so i do
think that there's a second
level of education and thought that has
to go into the jewish position
but i really think that the key at this
point is for white jews to confront
their whiteness
and i i agree and i i think that there's
um a really interesting um
uh the book the recent book cast by
isabel wilkerson
i think was one of the more interesting
books that i've read recently and it's
especially interesting i think
um because she relates um
uh race prejudice in america to nazi
germany and to the
to the i mean that's what that and the
indian caste system are her two examples
and so
it's fascinating to see an
african-american writer really thinking
hard
about the lessons of anti-semitism and
what they have to
um to teach us so uh
on that note anyway so i had a little
shout out for that for that book too so
anyway
thank you so much this was such a rich
and great
um talk and i really think um i i really
could not have asked for a better
lecture to really enlighten our
community on these issues so thank you
very very much
thank you so much it was truly a
pleasure